pues la ley de paridad que aún tiene que
tramitarse por el órgano legislativo
supone que o pretende que el 40% de los
órganos de decisión como lo dijiste de
la vida privada o pública o de la vida
política o económica esté formado por
mujeres o por hombres en caso de que
sean el género menos representado
algunos ejemplos de donde se aplicaría
esto pues por ejemplo en las listas
electorales unas listas que tendrían que
ser paritarias con los nombres alternos
de hombres y mujeres en lo que se conoce
como listas cremalleras listas que
afectarían a las elecciones municipales
o generales también a las de los
diputados para el parlamento europeo
pero lo más relevante por la gran brecha
de género que existe es en que se
aplicaría en las grandes empresas las de
más de 250 empleados o que facturen más
de 50 millones de euros anualmente Y es
que la representación de mujeres en los
consejos de administración de estas no
llega ni un 30% entonces con esta ley de
aprobarse lo que hasta ahora son solo
meras recomendaciones o códigos de
buenas prácticas o de buena conducta
sería una obligación así de aprobarse
España estaría cumpliendo con la
directiva europea dos años antes de la
fecha límite puesto que el bloque lo
tiene previsto para que entre en vigor
en julio de 2026 Sin embargo La idea es
que de aprobarse en España esta ley de
paridad entraría en vigor en julio de
2024 Marina pues Seguiremos de cerca la
tramitación de esta propuesta Pero hay
otro tema que está haciendo la piedra en
el zapato del gobierno del gobierno de
España desde hace una semana se trata de
la ley de libertad sexual una ley
recordemos que surgió tras el caso
conocido como la manada en que en 2016
recordemos cinco hombres violaron a una
joven de 18 años los hombres fueron a
solo condenados en un primer momento por
abuso sexual y no por violación algo que
luego rectificó el tribunal supremo hoy
el ala socialista del gobierno de la
coalición junto con unidad podemos ha
propuesto modificar la ley por qué
Pues porque esta ley que fue un clamor
social que surgió después de este caso
como bien decías y que a petición
popular lo que hace es unir dos penas en
uno lo que antes se diferenciaba entre
abuso o agresión dependiendo de si había
violencia o no todo se considera ahora
agresión independientemente de que haya
habido intimidación o no además también
se cambiaba lo que se lo que se
considera consentimiento antes el no
resistirse en el código penal anterior
el no resistirse se podía interpretar
como que había habido consentimiento
algo que la ley del solo sí es sí como
bien su nombre indica pretende o quiere
o obliga a que haya un consentimiento
claro y libre para que se considere que
había consentimiento sin embargo la
unión de estas dos penas de abuso y
agresión lo que ha hecho es que se hayan
Unido También las horquillas de penas
desde las más bajas hasta las más altas
y eso ha hecho que en la revisión de
penas que es un derecho constitucional
de los presos en
se hayan rebajado más de 700 penas
agresores sexuales y se haya excarcelado
a más de 70 agresores sexuales lo que ha
hecho saltar las alarmas por eso el psoe
quería modificar esta ley y es lo que se
ha debatido hoy en el congreso de los
diputados a mis espaldas pero lo que
pretende Entonces es que la violencia o
la intimidación se convierta en un en un
agravante más pero unidas podemos lo que
dice es que Entonces esto vuelve a poner
el foco de la atención en si la víctima
se ha resistido no es decir si ha habido
violencia o no y no en el consentimiento
que era el alma de esta ley del solo si
es Sí y una cosa más terminó todo esto
se da en contexto del 8m en el que
mañana miles de mujeres y de personas
saldrán a las calles de Madrid de nuevo
por segundo año divididas porque hay una
parte del feminismo que no está de
acuerdo con las políticas de la ministra
de igualdad de Irene Montero en temas
Como por ejemplo los derechos de las
personas lgbti y la prostitución o la
pornografía